it's award season again and today we're
talking about the Golden Globes but the
heck should we care about them well
where else you can see the rampant
alcoholism of Hollywood fired me
inspired I know the evening is getting
short I took a valium tonight so more
alcohol so you have para Golden Globes
and that's not even counting good old
Katniss ever steep but seriously with
everyone stoned out of their minds at
this thing this is so much more
entertaining the Oscars
hello Internet
welcome to film theory proudly nominated
for best speculation in a leading role
so let's just cut right to the chase
award shows can be pretty dumb like what
awards show giving an award to another
award show whose crew is working on the
current award show presenting the award
levels of dumb the Emmy goes to
Glenn Weiss for the 7th annual Tony
Awards today I still watch him because
let's be honest what else am I gonna
sarcastically live tweet about on a
Sunday night at matpat GT by the way
cash tag shameless self-promotion but
outside of the enormous ly rich creating
an event that types up their own hype i
also like watching these things to
figure out their patterns break the game
like say for instance that time i did a
two-part episode on how to hack the
oscars and said that the reason leonardo
dicaprio didn't win in his first four
nominations was that he was too young
and since the vast majority of Best
Actor Awards go to men over the age of
40 and wouldn't you know it a year after
I uploaded that video Leo happens to
pull out the win for the revenant at the
ripe old age of 41 nailed it you may not
have thanked me out loud during your
speech or on Twitter or have responded
to literally the thousands of tweets you
were getting about my video being
rightly o of it in my heart I knew I
knew anyway those videos were about how
to make movies that are Oscar winners
obviously helpful to my pal and loyal
theorist Leo DiCaprio most of you
watching so this year we're doing
something a bit more practical how to
win your office Oscar pool sure you
might not walk away with the gold statue
but you'll get something even better
cash straight out of your boss's pocket
and that's the sweetest cash of all so
after a year full of bad predictions
President Obama will go down as perhaps
the worst president in the history of
the United States exclamation point at
real Donald Trump at least I will go
down as a president I think just expect
this thing to dominate the cultural
conversation for a long time
posing today is that this group in rogue
one turns into this group from the
sequel trilogy let's start 2017 off
right by giving you the tools you need
to hack the Oscar now when I started
doing my homework on this episode I
expected to talk a lot about how
studying the Golden Globes would be the
best way to get your Oscar pics in order
I mean it is the first major award show
of the season and next to the Oscars is
by far the most watched of any of the
big movie awards but just going in and
plugging the Golden Globe winners into
your Oscar pool comes with some big
risks first credit where credit is due
the Golden Globes are really good at
picking out Best Actor and Best Actress
Awards in the last 20 years 70% of Best
Actor Oscar winners also won a Golden
Globe for that performance for Best
Actress that number shoots up to a
whopping 90 percent there are other
categories that have a really high
correlation between Oscar wins and
Golden Globe wins as well like
Screenplay at 80% know at first those
may seem like huge numbers and granted
they are but they're also a bit
misleading you see the Academy Awards
and Golden Globes don't give out these
awards in the same way sure 70% of best
actors and 90% of best actresses at the
Oscars also won themselves a Golden
Globe but that's because they had two
shots to do it the Golden Globe splits
its leading actor categories into
comedies and dramas so while it is
highly likely that one of those two
actors or actresses is going to win the
Academy Award how do you know which of
the two is it a 50-50 chance flip a coin
that don't fly here and for screenplays
it's the opposite problem one Oscar is
given for Best Original Screenplay and
one is given for Best Adapted Screenplay
whereas the Golden Globes just gives out
one for Screenplay and all those
technical awards that make or break your
prediction list like cinematography
sound mixing film editing not here my
friends and the last problem and
probably the biggest one is that the
Golden Globes have gotten worse in
predicting over the years from 1983 to
2003 one of the Golden Globe Film
winners for either Best Comedy or Best
Drama went on to win the Oscar for Best
Picture 18 out of 21 times very
respectable 86% of the time in the 12
years since though it's dropped to 33%
and it's basically made
two guesses every year that sucks
but it's also a really weird trend right
to go from being so good at guessing to
performing less than chance so what's
happening here
well we frankly it shows that the taste
of the American industry are becoming
more and more different from the tastes
of the rest of the world the Golden
Globes are handed out by the Hollywood
Foreign Press a group of journalists and
photographers that reports on the
entertainment industry for sites outside
of the US the Academy on the other hand
consists of about six thousand six
hundred people mostly us-based
historically ninety six percent white
and all being film industry
professionals with most still being
active in making movies but it's also
worth noting that this year it's six
thousand six hundred that extra six
hundred is noteworthy because those six
hundred were added just this year in
response to all the complaints about a
lack of diversity in the Academy is it
enough to sway the votes probably not
but you aren't gonna start to see things
shift away from the old guard and the
Academy probably overcorrect for the
sins of the last couple years
anyway TLDR the Golden Globes are fun at
all to see Jack Nicholson hopped up on
valium but if you're serious about
winning your Oscar pool you're gonna
have to go a lot deeper than that so
where does that mean we should turn well
I looked at the past 20 years of Awards
handed out by the Screen Actors Guild
Writers Guild of America Directors Guild
of America Producers Guild of America
BAFTA satellite Awards Critics Choice
National Society of Film Critics Online
Film Critics Society New York Film
Critics Circle in Los Angeles Film
Critics Association ooh if I never have
to write the name Meryl Streep into an
Excel spreadsheet again I will die a
happy man obviously there was a ton of
data to wade through so I'm gonna give
you the cliff notes and tell you the
three biggest lessons learned about
Oscar predictability from this little
data analysis project I did number one
trust the Guild's in that laundry list
of award shows I just rattled off you
heard four guilds mentioned the Screen
Actors Guild the Directors Guild of
America The Producers Guild of America
and the Writers Guild of America
these awards largely go under the radar
but they shouldn't each one of them was
the single best predictor of the awards
that they specialize in this
Actors Guild predicted the best actor
award 80% of the time and the best
actress award 75% of the time the
Writers Guild selected the ultimate
winner for adapted an original
screenplay at a rate of 70% each the
directors guild picked the Best Director
Oscar winner 85% of the time well ahead
of any of the other award shows and the
most accurate predictor for Best Picture
is an award you probably didn't even
know existed The Producers Guild of
America Award at 70% this all makes
sense right they're focused on the
American voting bloc and they're all
specialized in their individual
categories logic lesson number two
ignore the critics in my data analysis I
mentioned that I included the pics of
several critics associations and Lee mr.
poopy potholes was that a waste of time
the New York Film Critics Circle LA Film
Critics Association Online Film Critics
Society and National Society of Film
Critics are not only very redundant and
what they've named their organizations
but are also very unreliable across the
board none none of those four award
shows picked the Oscar winner in any
category more than half the time any
category and their Best Picture picks
were especially bad the Los Angeles Film
Critics Society picked the Best Picture
Oscar winner twice in the last one two
years
seriously we must have some bitter
failed filmmakers in the LA Film Critics
Society because with a 10 percent
accuracy rate it seems like they are
intentionally trying to go against the
grain we got some hipsters over here
hipster alerts that said there is one
exception the Critics Choice Awards are
actually surprisingly good at picking
Best Cinematography which it's done 85
percent of the time and Best Original
Screenplay which had only missed once in
the 11 times that it's handed out the
award it's when it comes to those more
obscure categories that's a good one to
reference which brings us to lesson
number three award shows themselves
aren't enough sure a 70% accuracy rating
for a given category is pretty good but
as any of you who watch our GT live
livestreams know I'm not a big fan of
losing
and I want you to be confident that
you're finally gonna get some bragging
rights over bill from accounting
he is so smug screw you bill you and
your accounting whatever accountants
have a computer to general of your
calculator yeah that got him got it good
but seriously you guys can relate right
every office school classroom whatever
has that like one film hipster oh I
can't believe that they snubbed this
obscure Iranian Foreign Film well screw
them czar time shine today I set out to
give you the best way to make your
predictions the best odds to have the
ability to rub it in those film hipster
faces and dang it I intend to deliver
luckily the best answer to this problem
is the answer that I use for practically
every problem these days the Internet
that may seem vague but stick with me
the digital age has really changed the
amount of data that we can collect on
what people are thinking and as a result
the likeliest outcomes of things that
people have to decide if you're just
looking through other award shows and
how predictive they are you only really
have a few data points to go off of for
predicting any one award but some
analysts are starting to create new
models to predict the Academy Awards
that consider thousands if not millions
of data points take for instance my
favorite short form sarcasm generator
and meme filter Twitter last year a data
scientist named pulsing man ventured to
make a model that predicted the Oscars
based off the volume of Twitter mentions
and rankings of how positive they work
sure it wasn't perfect but Sigmund's
model got a lot of the awards right like
Best Actor Best Actress Best Director
Best Original Score and Best Animated
Feature and that was the models first
ever test drive with more results added
to the model to see what it got right
and what it got wrong from last year
it's highly likely that his model this
year is gonna be even more accurate
still even Symons model miss probably
what was the biggest upset of last year
Best Picture
picking the revenant over the actual
winner of spotlights but seriously
everyone missed that one in fact
spotlight actually became the first film
in over 60 years to win Best Picture
while only winning one other award in
analyzing all these different strategies
it was the biggest outlier to try to
account for how do you predict the
unpredictable
I mean seriously did anybody see that
win for spotlight coming well yes but
not someone some thing
it took a lottery
search and a lot of trial and error but
I finally found it Skynet I mean sorry
Google Google Google's why I meant a
quick look at the Google Trends data for
the search terms the revenant the big
short and spotlights starting at the
beginning of 2016 shows us an
interesting pattern in all of those
graphs we see a big spike in the week of
February 28th and that's to be expected
since that's when the Oscars were handed
out but it's the shape of the graph in
January and early February that's the
most interesting both the revenant and
the big short came into 2016 with very
hot search traffic but then cooled down
significantly the couple of weeks
leading up to the Oscars spotlight on
the other hand started very flat but
gradually grew consistently growing in
search traffic through the first six
weeks of 2016 it's plausible that these
models of search traffic mirror the
behavior of Academy voters if voters for
the Oscars checked out the big short in
the revenant while they were hot and
searched traffic in early January it's
likely that they were watching films
that received fewer accolades like
spotlight a bit closer to the time that
they were actually voting the couple of
weeks right before the big awards
thereby making them subject to our good
old friend the recency effect a
psychological phenomenon which states
that we are more likely to remember and
prefer things that we've seen or watched
more recently so while the Big Short in
the revenant were distant memories in
the voters Minds having Jesse and
spotlight everybody's gonna be
interested in this that's the one they
vote for but simply you don't want your
movie to be losing steam as it heads
into the Oscars because the two weeks
before the ceremony is when the voting
really happens so here we are this is it
this is the moment bill from accounting
has headed down the hall waving that
Oscar ballot in his grubby little hands
looking as cocky as always thoughts of
that eye radiant documentary running
through his head what are you gonna do
to wipe that grin off his face let me
tell you step one
follow the Guild's look up the winners
from each respective guild and mark them
off add in some of the categories that
we mentioned from the Critics Choice
step two double check your choices with
Twitter trends and step three before you
turn in your ballot the Friday before
the Oscars double check Google Trends to
see if any underdogs have been gaming in
search and finally step four watch the
ceremony and
celebrate as the points come rolling in
and when Monday morning rolls around rub
you're astute choice of best foreign
film documentary and Bill's face because
at the end of the day who cares which
multi-millionaire walked away with a
golden statue all that matters is you
winning bragging rights for the next
year screw you bill you and your
calculator just because it has subtitles
doesn't make it good
but hey that's just a theory of film
theory
and cut